a really strange scene to describe
because the lanes here leading into the
ferry at the Port of Dover are starting
to look like some sort of school County
away day you can see clearly how many of
the coaches and buses that are parked up
here not moving that have been here
overnight in some cases for 12 14 hours
in and around the Dover area and they've
grown clearly absolutely Fed Up and
frustrated of sitting in those vehicles
of waiting of trying to get any Glimpse
or hint of sleep and the school children
have started to pile out onto the lanes
themselves I've heard them singing I've
seen them playing rugby and other sorts
of sports and just generally trying to
stretch their legs that gives you a
sense of course I think of how long
they're waiting they've been waiting
already and how long they know they've
still got to wait because even though
they're actually here now finally at the
ferry port itself there is a long way to
go several hours I think facing at any
of the coaches that you can see here
because they're at the back of this
particular queue and it's been a
nightmare for so many people
particularly all of these school trips I
was just chatting to one teacher who's
taking two coach loads of school
children on a skiing trip they should be
strapping their boots on right now on
the slopes as they were meant to be
crossing the channel at around eight
o'clock last night instead he's just
been sent out to order around a thousand
pounds worth of dominoes in a pizza
delivery order a pizza delivery order he
said because the school children of
course they've got no food left on the
coach and you can see really how this is
such a serious situation for them many
of the drivers now they've been maxed
out on their hours so even once they get
across the channel and they try and
continue on their Journeys people are
having to find hotels these teachers
having to book new drivers and the whole
thing really becoming a logistical
nightmare that has come at this pinch
point of the first weekend of the Easter
holidays and real questions now for the
port of Dover and for the fairy
authorities as well to have to answer
why didn't see this coming and what went
so badly wrong we know that post-brexit
passport checks have been blamed also
the port itself blaming the French
border officials and the lengthy delays
and we also know there were more coaches
than they expected and while in a
statement the port of Dover have said
that extra Ferry Crossings which were
put on overnight have started to ease
things started to ease the backlog
they're still expecting delays of six to
eight hours for many of these coaches
arriving now as I mentioned already I've
been speaking to people who've been
waiting for 16 hours already and
Counting
[Music]